this next clip is truly a pleasure to
watch and it is exactly what i have been
recommending be done
when dealing with right-wing media
engage in conversation
but get them on the record did trump win
or lose in 2020
let's start there just so we know who
and what we're dealing with here
the daily beast reports that yesterday
during an appearance on fox news
i'm sorry the day before yesterday texas
state uh representative
james talarico a democrat young guy
challenged pete hegseth to tell his
viewers
that donald trump lost the 2020
presidential election to joe biden
heg seth refused to just confirm
yes trump lost which really proves
the guest's point in trying to get him
on the record about this and talarico
quickly started going after fox news he
eventually demanded hey pete
say that trump lost say it let's take a
look at it
this is just fantastic someone in your
district that can't get identification
you have made a lot of money personally
and you've enriched a lot of
corporations with advertising by getting
on here and spewing lies
and conspiracy theories to folks who
trust about myself and so what i'm
asking you to do is
tell your voters right now that donald
trump okay
that is resolved the lie that is did
democrats
account for voter id it's not just sir
but at least
real quick can you answer the question
did donald trump i think the election
is running questions i'm not don't is
this
uncomfortable or anything so i think he
i think he said
seth they're meant to say i'm asking
questions not answering them
but he's he seems so tripped up question
for you no it's because this is the
three my question is why are you in
washington dc and not in
someone he's in washington dc because
texas republicans
threatened texas democrats with arrest
with arrest
if they didn't show up in order to
prevent a quorum
in order to prevent a disgusting texas
voter suppression bill from from passing
but as far as the clip goes
i just absolutely love that every
democratic
guest should be doing that every time
they appear on these networks but but
oh but david sir they're not being
brought on to talk about whether trump
once so it's sandbagging it's wrong for
them to do
i don't care make them kick you off make
them never invite you back
if every single democratic guest starts
asking this
it's going to very quickly put them in a
really awkward position but like i've
been saying
do this in every interview with
republican officials as well
when whoever on whatever channel
interviews a republican official asks
them
just for context did donald trump win or
lose
the 2020 election and many of them have
figured out how to play coy
many of them you say did trump win the
election or did trump lose the election
and they would say
listen joe biden is the president of the
united states that's what matters
because what they're
what they're avoiding answering is
whether joe biden
should be based on the election results
that's how they play coy with it and so
even asking the question
the host still is going to have to be
prepared but
i think that this is uh an important
thing to do because at the end of the
day
what's the point of interviewing people
when they can't even be on the same page
about basic facts
would we trust them about any of their
views on politics
if they can't even acknowledge who won
the 2020 election
think about it analogously if we did a
series on
space travel and i suspected a guest
believed the earth was flat
and i start the interview by saying is
the earth flat or
or spherical and they won't answer why
would i keep talking about space travel
with that person
and the interview they can't have we
can't even get to a simple foundational
uh infrastructure about just the
fundamentals of how the world works why
would i continue talking about space
travel and similarly in political
interviews
do you accept that donald trump
genuinely not because of
fraud or fraud just he just lost if you
don't accept that why are we going to
talk to you about your views on politics
it's a simple screening question
really nicely done by james talarico i
hope
i hope that this becomes a trend where
democratic guests will say this to
right-wing hosts
and hosts will act ask republican guests
did trump win or did trump lose answer
that question before we move on i would
love to see it and we'll have more on
this strategy
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find
at david pakman show this is crazy but
nearly a hundred thousand followers on
the david pakman show instagram
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much more after this
our sponsor purevpn is having a huge
14th anniversary sale offering everybody
in my audience a subscription for under
three bucks
a month purevpn is a service
i trust because it has more servers than
any other vpn on the market
and it's the only vpn with an always-on
third-party audit to verify
that your internet activity is not being
logged
purevpn keeps me anonymous online keeps
me safe from hackers government
surveillance
any websites trying to track me and it
lets me
also access awesome streaming content
which wouldn't otherwise be available in
my country on platforms like netflix and
a whole bunch of others
i can stay logged into purevpn on up to
10 of my devices at the same time
and it's so easy to use you click two
buttons to set it up
you need no computer expertise at all
you can get pure vpn at a huge discount
just 288 a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is right under this video
and you'll get
an additional 14 off when you use the
coupon code
hbd 14.